WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME TO ANOTHER-
HEARING OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH WITH ADMITTED WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
I WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT TODAY. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX FOUR SIX
FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN
I WILL REPEAT. THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE FOUR
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER. TO THE SENATE AND
ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO. FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE SURE THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR
CALL YOU. TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER SO WAIT AND THEN YOU'LL
BE CALLED. AT THAT TIME IT WILL
BE ON MUTED AND YOU WILL BE
ABLE AND READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID. ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK OR ECHOES YOU
MUST MUTE YOUR DEVICE THAT YOU
WERE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE BUT
REMEMBER PLEASE TURN OFF THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING US
YOU'RE LISTENING TO. ONCE YOU
GET TO SPEAK. I'LL OBVIOUSLY
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS BEING
DISRUPTIVE BABY REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONVERSATIONS MUTED
SO HOPEFULLY EVERYBODY CAN NOW
PRACTICE GOOD BEHAVIOR AS WELL.
AND SHARE THEIR COMMENTS- WITH
US BECAUSE WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU- IT IS ALSO A GOOD TIME TO
REMIND EVERYBODY THAT IS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY TODAY. THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. AND SO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL THAT YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON.
WE REALLY DON'T WANT TO RE
LITIGATE THE POLICY MEASURES
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE POINT OF
THE POLICY COMMITTEE SO-
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING PRIOR
POLICY ARGUMENTS. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LIFETIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WERE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE
OF THE ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. FOR ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE TWENTY SEVEN
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA ALL O
WHICH ARE SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATES. AND WE WILL ALSO BE
ADOPTING THE COMMITTEE RULES
THERE ARE THREE MEASURES ON
FILE THAT WILL NOT BE HEARD
TODAY WILL BE INSTEAD BE
SCHEDULED FOR LATER HEARINGS SB.
TWO THIRTY PORTANTINO. SB TWO
SIX SEVEN HERTZBERG. AND S.
THREE OF FOUR DRESS. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILL
I WANT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
SO. MISTER CONSULT WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
PORTANTINO I'M HERE DO YOU KNOW
HERE BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD
HERE JONES. KAMLAGER KAMLAGER
HERE LAYERED HERE LATER HERE
CASKEY HERE ASKING HERE. THE
REPORT WE HAVE A QUORUM I ALSO
WANT TO EXTEND A WELCOME TO OUR
NEW SENATE COLLEAGUE MS COME
LONGER THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
CENTER. GREAT TO HAVE YOU- WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN HEARING OUR BILLS-
TODAY'S AGENDA SO BEFORE WE DO
THAT WE HAVE TO A JOB THE
RULES. AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE COMMITTEE RULES ARE ADOPTED
I SEE NO OBJECTION SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THE COMMITTEE RULES
ARE ADOPTED SO LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE BUSINESS OF THE DAY. DUE TO
RESTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF THE HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE- SO I'M IN
A LIMIT TESTIMONY TO TWO
MINUTES. FOR EACH PRIMARY
WITNESS AND THEN- FOR ME TO USE
IT'LL JUST BE NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION AND
SO THE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IF
WE HAVE ANY CAN HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH- AND THEN EVERYONE
ELSE WILL LIMIT THEIR-
COMMENTS. ACCORDINGLY TO THE
FIRST ITEM ON OUR AGENDA IS S.
B. NINETEEN BY SENATOR GLAZER
WHICH IS ONLINE. WINE GROWERS-
TASTING ROOMS- IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE HE'S WAY PRESENTATION
SO MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR ANYONE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT. AND SO WE'LL MOVE TO
THE PUBLIC MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHAT WANTING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP ANY INDIVIDUALS WANTED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINETEEN. NOW IS THE TIME.
THANK YOU. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONCE AGAIN MY
COMMANDERS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I DO
SHOW ONE WIND QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. AUTHORED OF A DIFFERENT
BRAND NEW CASES. I DISTRICT
MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GO RIGHT TO THE LINE YES PLEASE.
THANK YOU BLIND TWELVE ONE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOODNESS
THANK YOU COLOR ON LINE TWELVE
IS THIS THE BILL YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK ON. NO IT IS NOT THANK
YOU MAY RE QUEUE. AND WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT- WE WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION IF THERE'S ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN THIS ROOM
FOR SB NINETEEN IN OPPOSITION
THERE IS NONE IS THERE ANYBODY
IN FROM TWENTY FORTY THERE IS
NONE MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD QUEUE UP ANYBODY WHO IS
IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINETEEN
NOW IS THE TIME. THANK YOU
COULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
GIVEN THAT OF THE ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. YEAH.
IT WAS THE LAST. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT- SEEING
THAT THERE IS NO SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THANK YOU
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW COME BACK
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WHICH I UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO
FILE ON S. B. NINETEEN SO-
COLLEAGUES- THERE'S BEEN NO.
COMMENTARY EITHER WAY AND
THERE'S NO FINANCE REPORT THIS
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. NINETEEN WILL
BE MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON SB FORTY
ONE BY SENATOR I'M BURKE ON
PRIVACY GENETIC TESTING- THE
NEXT ITEM- THIS IS ALSO A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MR AMERICA'S
WAY PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FORTY ONE- SEEING NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM ISN'T SAYING NO
ONE IN TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FORTY ONE NOW IS THE TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FORTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
DO HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. BE JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY SEVEN TWO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS M.
BLACKWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
ANCESTRY AND TWENTY THREE ME IN
THE PARK. FINE SUCCINCT
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME NO FURTHER LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION A SINGLE ONE IN THIS
ROOM STEPPING FORWARD TO OPPOSE
AND SEE NO ONE IN TWENTY FORTY-
STEPPING FORWARD MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION SB FORTY
ONE. THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SP FORTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THE NEW
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE BEEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AND THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN HERE AT THIS TIME.
HAVING IT TAKING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER. BOTH PRO
AND CON- TESTIMONY AND HAVING
NONE IT'S MY UNDERSTAND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON SB FORTY ONE SO
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO HANDS REYES UP-
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FORTY ONE
WILL BE MOVED TO SUSPENSE FILE.
MOVING ON S. B. FIFTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR DORADO ON MEDI CAL
ELIGIBILITY- IT'S OUR NEXT
AGENDA ITEM- THIS IS ALSO A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY-
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING TO
SUPPORT SB FIFTY SIX. I SEE
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
WISHING TO SUPPORT- S. B. FIFTY
SIX MISTER MODERATOR FISH
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
WANTING TO BE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY SIX NOW IS THE TIME.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. FIFTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN MY COMMANDERS ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT ON SB
FIFTY SIX. WE WILL GO FIRST TO
LINE SIXTEEN ONE SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS CINDY
HILLARY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY SIX THANKS SO MUCH.
YEAH RIGHT NEXT WE HAVE LINE
THIRTY ONE THREE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING NATALIE
COOPER FROM THE OPEN MARKET OR
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY IF THEY
NEED TO GO IN SUPPORT. OUR NEXT
COMMENT AS LINE TWENTY THREE TO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU AND GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KAREN GOING BACK AND THE SENIOR
SENATOR AND THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WE HAVE COMMENT FROM LINE
TWENTY TWO ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MARIO AS POLITICAL BUT
A GIRL CAN THAT IT IS A DOLLARS
YET UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SANTA BARBARA IF YOU THINK
YOU'RE TO THEIR MY ON A
SCHOLAR. I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE.
MY STRONG SUPPORTER SB FIVE
SIX. HE DUG OUT. THEY'RE
WALKING HERE. YOU HAVE A
COMMENT THE FROM LINE TWENTY
EIGHT TO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RIGHT WELL- THIS IS
REBECCA THEM BOTH THE NATIONAL
AT THE OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. TEN AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY SIX ALL
RIGHT WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
SB FIFTY SIX SAYING NO AND
RUSHED TO THE MICROPHONE IN
THIS ROOM. WILL MOVE TO TWENTY
FORTY SEEING EMPTY CHAIRS IN
TWENTY FORTY WE WILL GO ONLINE
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY SIX
NOW IS THE TIME. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIFTY
SIX ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. ONCE
AGAIN MY COMMANDERS ONE MM.
ZERO THERE ARE NO LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
HAVING OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR BOTH PRO AND CON- TESTIMONY
WE WILL MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WHICH HAS A FILE ON
SB FIFTY SIX GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOE
LEONE- WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WE CURRENTLY DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL.
THAT WOULD KNOW THAT ASSUMING
IMPLEMENTATION ON JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THIS BILL IS
PRELIMINARY. TO INCREASE
MEDICARE ALL AN IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES COSTS BY
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION OF
WHICH WOULD BE GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
AND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH
WOULD BE GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. WITH
ONGOING GROWTH- IN ADDITION
NECESSARY SYSTEM CHANGES AND
STATE OPERATIONS RESOURCES
WOULD BE NEEDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES- THE GENERAL FUND COST
OF SYSTEM CHANGES AND THESE
OTHER OPERATE. NOT AT THIS TIME
ABOUT WOULD LIKELY BE IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TAKING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIFTY
SIX WILL MOVE FOR THE SUSPENSE
FILE. MOVING TO SB SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR TADO ON WORKFORCE
TRAINING SERVICES- THE ITEM IS
ALSO SUSPENDS CANDIDATE IN
MISSOURI TODD OF HIS WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB SIXTY ONE AGAIN THERE'S
NO RUSH TO THE MICROPHONE IN
THIS ROOM. AND TWENTY FORTY
REMAINS EMPTY MISTER MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD- QUEUE UP ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY ONE NOW
IS THE TIME. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD THAT IS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. IT WILL BE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE DO HAVE AT LEAST ONE
COMMON IN Q.
ARE. COMMON IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SIX ONE IS
FROM LINE FOURTEEN ONE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING
SIR CARE NUMBER OF KAREN LAYING
ON TOP OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND RIGHT THIS
MORNING THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
THIS TIME NO OTHER LINES ARE IN
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION SEEING NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN OPPOSITION TO NO
ONE IN TWENTY FORTY IN
OPPOSITION MISTER MODERATOR. HE
WOULD QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
TO SB SIXTY ONE NOW IS THE TIME.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY ONE THE
PROPOSAL ON WOMEN'S ZERO USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. INDIAN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB. SIX
ONE. COLONEL LINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THE
DEPARTMENT FINEST IS NOT HAVE A
FILE ON SB SIXTY ONE SO WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIXTY ONE MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING ON TO
SB SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA
ON MOBILE HOME PARKS EMERGENCY
RELIEF- THE ITEM IS ALSO A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN HIS LEYVA
HAS WAY PRESENTATION SO WE'LL
MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
FOR ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF SB SIXTY FOUR.
SAYING NO ONE IN THIS ROOM COME
TO THE MICROPHONE SING TWENTY
FORTY STILL EMPTY- WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY FOUR. THANK
YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY FOUR YOU MEAN PRESS ONE
AND THEN THEY'RE ALL USING YOUR
TELEPHONE. THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX FOUR. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
HAVE BEEN TAKING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER SUPPORT-
TESTIMONY WITHOUT OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ONE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE OPPOSING NO ONE IN TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED ASTRONOMY MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. SB SIXTY
FOUR. NOW IS THEIR TIME. THANK
YOU TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN THE
COMMAND OF THE ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
WE'LL GO FIRST. TO LINE OF LINE
EIGHT. EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE TWELVE ONE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR CHRIS WYSOCKI FOR
THE WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
WE BELIEVE THAT THE- SB SIX
DEPORT CONTAIN SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURES ON ELLIE AIDS. H. C.
D. AND THE COURT SYSTEM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT I HAVE BEEN TAKING-
SUPPORT OPPOSITION ON SB SIXTY
FOUR. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON SB
SIXTY FOUR SO COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIXTY
FOUR WILL BE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE MOVING S. B. TWO
OH FIVE BY SENATOR LIVE ON
SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES- THAT'S OUR NEXT ITEM
IT'S ALSO A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AND WAS LEYVA HAS WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY. ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO OH FIVE NOW IS YOUR
TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM. THERE'S NO ONE IN TWENTY
FORTY MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO OH FIVE NOW IS THERE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO OH FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD THAT IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF TWO ZERO FIVE. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. ALL RIGHT NOW IS OPPOSITIONS
OPPORTUNITY FOR S. B. TWO OH
FIVE SEEING NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM. SEE NO ONE IN TWENTY
FORTY MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
S. B. TWO OH FIVE. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
OR FIVE ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AMEND THEIR- AT THIS TIME.
WE DO HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WELL I AM THIRTY
FIVE THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING ALL OF
THAT AFTER ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- AS
REFLECTED IN THE NOTE AND THEN
ALEX'S IF THE COULD POTENTIALLY
BE AN ATTEMPT BUT COULD
POTENTIALLY COST IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS HELLO HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS STATEWIDE
EACH YEAR. AND THERE'S NO AND
NO FUNDING PROVIDED IN THE BILL
FOR- FOR THIS MANDATE THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU HAVING
HEARD FROM THE THOSE SUPPORT
AND- OPPOSITION. I WILL NOW
MOVE TO DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY
DO NOT HAVE A FILE. ON S. B.
TWO OH FIVE SO WE'LL COME RIGHT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. TWO OH FIVE.
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
TO OUR NEXT FILL. SB TWO
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR LEYVA ON DNA
EVIDENCE. AS OUR NEXT ITEM IT'S
ALSO A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN
THIS LEYVA HAS WAY PRESENTATION
SO MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB TWO
FIFTEEN SEE NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FIFTEEN. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FIFTEEN ME
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO LINES
IN Q. ALL RIGHT NOW MOVING TO
OPPOSITION- THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN OPPOSITION IS
KNOWN IN TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATE P. PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO FIFTEEN
NOW IS THE TIME. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TWO FIFTEEN ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT HAVING OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH FOR AND
AGAINST THE TESTIMONY WE WILL
MOVE TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WHICH DOES NOT HAVE A FILE AND
I SPEAK TO FIFTEEN SO WE'LL
COME RIGHT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO
FIFTEEN. WILL GO TO SUSPEND.
MOVING TO SB THREE OH NINE BY
SENATOR LABEL ON LIVE ON SCHOOL
FINANCE COLLEGE READINESS- THIS
ITEM IS ALSO A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE
WILLING TO WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
SINGING ALONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MISTER MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ONLINE IT WOULD WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE OH NINE. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE OH NINE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO IS IN OPPOSITION SB
THREE ARE NOT. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
ZERO NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IN THE
COMMANDOS ONE AND THAT WAS ZERO.
AND THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT- THAT
WAS OPPOSITION RIGHT. YES YES
BY MY COUNT YET THANK YOU
PUTTING NOBODY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WILL MOVE TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
UNDERSTAND IT FROM A FINANCE
DOES HAVE A FILE ON SB THREE
ARE NOT SUFFICIENT MISTER CHAIR
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL THIS TIME AROUND AS
FAR AS THE FISCAL IN ADDITION
TO APPROPRIATING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. TO SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A GRANT
PROGRAM I TARGETED AT THOSE
ELEAZAR MEETING SPECIFIC ATG
COMPLETION ACTUAL OF THE BILL
MAY CREATE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE AND THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND BOB I
EXPLICITLY INCLUDING THE ATG
SUBJECT MATTER REQUIREMENTS AS
PART OF THE COURSE OF STUDIES A
STUDY THAT ALLEY IS REQUIRED TO
OFFER. TO OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS THIS BILL. MAY ALSO
CREATE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE. OTHERS BY REQUIRING
ALL LEN THAT SERVE A GREATER
AND HIGH STUDENTS PROVIDE
PARENTS AND FAMILIES BUT
CERTAIN INFORMATION. RELATED TO
THEIR SCHOOLS EDG COURSES AND
REQUIREMENTS. ARE TO THE EXTENT
OF THE GRANT PROGRAM AND WITH
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
INCREASED ADG COMPLETION RATES
AND LEAD YOU SEE ANDERSON AS
YOU SEEK. STATE FUNDING FOR A
MOMENT INCREASES. THIS BILL
WOULD RESULT IN POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SEE NO HANDS GO UP FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THREE OH NINE. IS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. WE WILL MOVE ON
TO SB FIVE SIX SIX BY SENATOR
LEYVA. ON CSU SUPPORT STAFF
MERIT SALARIES- THIS ITEM IS
ALSO SUSPENDS CANDIDATE AND THE
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
MOVE RIGHT ON TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. ANYONE WILLING JUST
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
NOW IS YOUR TIME SEEING NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM. SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. OF SB FIVE
SIX SIX. THANK YOU THIS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE SIX SIX
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN THAT IS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WILL BE JUST A MOMENT FOR
A COMMENT. GO TO A LINE OF
THIRTY FOUR THREE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PROBABLY
ACTUALLY SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
DRUG COURT THANK YOU. TURN
ORDER LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOT OPPOSITION SEEING NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM IN STEPPING
FORWARD WE WILL MOVE TO. TWENTY
FORTY SINGH KNOWN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THIS MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ONLINE IN
OPPOSITION SB FIVE SIXTY SIX
NOW IS THE TIME. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
SIX SIX PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. THANK MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHTS HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WE WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT PART IN
FINANCE DOES HAVE A FILE ON SB
FIVE SIXTY SIX. SO- WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
THIS TIME. WE WOULD ESTIMATE
THE COST OF APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS IN THE FIRST
YEAR APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY FIVE
POINT FOUR MILLION IN THE
SECOND YEAR A GROWING ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. THE CHANCES OFFICE
ESTIMATED AGGREGATE COSTS COULD
EXCEED ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS. I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
BECAUSE THE BILL REQUIRES CSU
TO FUND ITS PROVISIONS WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES. UP THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL
WOULD LIKELY DIVERT A
COMMENSURATE LEVEL OF RESOURCES
FROM OTHER U PURPOSES. WHICH
COULD RESULT IN PROGRAMMATIC
REDUCTIONS TO OTHER SYSTEM WIDE
ACTIVITIES OR CREATE A GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES. THANK YOU
FINO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE SIX SIX WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB
NINETY SEVEN FIVE. GENERAL ROTH
ON PEOPLE HEALTH TYPE ONE
DIABETES THE ITEM IS ALSO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND THE
GENERAL HAS WAY PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL MOVE RIGHT ON TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT NOW IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY. SEE NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM SIGNAL IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP SUPPORT FOR S. B.
NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
SEVEN MAY PRESS ONE NUMBER ZERO.
AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON
TO OPPOSITION THIS OR ANYONE
OPPOSED SB NINETY SEVEN NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM. NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TWENTY ONE ONLINE
OPPOSED S. B. NINETY SEVEN. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINETY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN THE
COMMANDERS ONE ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THERE ARE NO
LINES INTO IT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT HAVE BEEN TAKEN IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION-
ADDITION IS INFORMATIVE FINEST
IS NOT A FILING SB NINETY SEVEN
SO COME RIGHT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINETY
SEVEN IS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. WILL MOVE TO MISTER
MCGUIRE- OUR NEXT BILL IS SB
NINETY EIGHT. ON PUBLICPEACE
MEDIA ACCESS- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MR REQUIRES
WE'VE PRESENTATION SOME OF
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY EIGHT NOW
IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY SAYING NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM SIGNAL ON IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE OF
ANYONE ONLINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
EIGHT. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY EIGHT ME
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
JENNIFER SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
EIGHT IT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO LINES
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WELL MOVED
OPPOSITION OF SB NINETY EIGHT.
SEE NO ONE IN THIS ROOM WHO IS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SB NINETY EIGHT WE
WILL MOVE TO REDUCE FROM TWENTY
FORTY. THERE'S NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION IN TWENTY FOURTEEN A
SERRANO WRITER PLEASE COMPANY
ONE ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING
TO OPPOSE SB NINETY EIGHT.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINETY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. YEAH THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT AS
WELL HAVING TAKEN BOTH OPPOSE
AND SUPPORT OPPORTUNITY WILL
MOVE TO PARMA FINANCE WHICH
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON SB
NINETY EIGHT SO WE'LL BRING IT
RIGHT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINETY EIGHT WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO S. B.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE BY SEVEN
ACQUIRE ON CALIFORNIA TOURISM
RECOVERY ACT THIS IS ALSO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND MR
MCGUIRE HAS WAY PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL MOVE RIGHT ON TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THIS IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MOST MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ONLINE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB TWO EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU THIS IS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. CAN NOT USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE DO HAVE A LINE IN Q.
B. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY THAT
FIVE MARKET. WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF THIRTY NINE THREE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS AMANDA
WALDRON WITH TRIPLE A AUTO CLUB
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EXPRESSING OUR SUPPORT FOR SB
TWO EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANKS WE DO HAVE ADDITIONAL
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
EIGHTY FIVE WOULD BE JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT PLEASE. RIGHT
BOB. CONNECT COMMENT IS FROM
LINE THIRTY TWO THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS APPOINTED ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES
IMPORTANCIA. AND WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THAT COMES FROM
LINE FORTY ONE FOUR ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JERRY MEMBERS
JERRY DESMOND IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE UP TO HALF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF TRAVEL
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WELL NOW
GOT OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO
EIGHTY FIVE THIS IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY. SEE NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM TO MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NO ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FORTY. MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE OF ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO EIGHTY
FIVE THE MAIN QUEUE UP AT THIS
TIME USING ONE OF THE BY ZERO.
YOU CAN ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT. MY
UNDERSTAND IS FORMER FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON S. B.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE HAVING HEARD
BOTH FOR AND AGAINST
OPPORTUNITIES WE WILL COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE WHICH I SEE NO
HANDS GO UP SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. TWO EIGHTY
FIVE. WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO SENATOR NIELSEN SB
ONE OH ONE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLE RECORDS AND
CONFIDENTIALITY- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND MISTER
NELSON IS WAY PRESENTATION SO
MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT NOW IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY
SIGNAL IN FORTY TWO OH THREE.
SAY KNOWN IN TWENTY FORTY
MISTER MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ONLINE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE A ONE. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE ON
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL COLORS AND CAME TO ME
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. OUR. FROM
LINE TEN ONE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THIS IS A LEVEL WITH THE-
OF. BOARDMAN OFFICE SUPPORT
YEAH BUT WHAT AT THE BOTTOM WHY
DON'T. THE BALLOT. OR CALL THE
BILL. LANGUAGE THAT PROVIDE
THAT EXPENSES FOR- INCLUDING
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WITH
WOULD BE BORNE BY THE
INDIVIDUAL UP. THE TECHNICIAN
HAS A PRICE THANK YOU OUR NEXT
COMMENT IS FROM LINE TWENTY TWO
TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO SB MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JENNIFER MORRIS AND THE
SUPERVISING CONTEMPLATION
OFFICER FOR THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY CODE ENFORCEMENT
CANNABIS TO BEFORE SPENT TEAM.
I CURRENTLY AM ALSO EMBEDDED
WITH RIVERSIDE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CANNABIS TASK FORCE.
MY TEAMS ROSE TO STRUGGLING
CRIMINALLY ADDRESS ADDRESS-
CANNABIS GROW AS WELL AS
CANNABIS DISPENSARY. I DEAL
DAILY WITH THOSE WHO ARE MAKING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN THE ILLEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET. STOPPING OR
ENCOURAGEMENT COULD GREATLY
BENEFIT THOSE WHO OPERATE
WITHIN THE ILLEGAL CANNABIS
MARKET. THIS PUTS US COULDN'T
OFFICER AT GREAT RISK. AT THE
CURRENT PORCELAIN OFFICER I AM
THE ONLY ONE ON THE TASK FORCE
GOOD NOT HAVE THE PROTECTION OF
A CONFIDENTIAL LICENSE PLATE.
EVEN EVIDENCE TECHNICIAN WHO IS
ON THE TASK FORCE. THAT BENEFIT.
THERE WAS AN INCIDENT IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WHERE
DISGRUNTLED PROPERTY OWNER TOOK
PHOTOS OF ALL OF THE CODE
ENFORCEMENT EMPLOYEES PERSONAL
CAR LICENSE PLATE. WE'VE BEEN
PLACED ON CRAIGSLIST
IDENTIFYING THE VEHICLE AS CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS VEHICLE.
SB ONE NO ONE SHOULD NOT BE PUT
ON SUSPENSE FILE BECAUSE THIS
BILL HAS NO COST DIMENSION. SB
ONE OH ONE SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDES WITH THE COST OF
ACQUIRING FOR PRIVACY
PROTECTION FROM THE DMV IS
BORNE BY EACH INDIVIDUAL
CANDIDATE. PLEASE CONSIDER NOT
PUTTING THE EXPERIAN PORTANTINO
INTEREST EXPENSE IT COULD BE
THE MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'LL
CONSIDER THOSE THE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES SO ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE CONFINE YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE UP THIRTY
SEVEN THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
THIS TEAM MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DON BALON THE CODE ENFORCEMENT
MANAGER FOR THE CITY DALY CITY
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF. OF
KCON ASKING YOU TO NOT PLACE SB
ONE A ONE IN THE SUSPENSE FILE
AS S. B. ONE OH ONE- THERE ARE
NO COST DIMENSIONS AS MENTIONED
EARLIER- THIS COST WALL BE
OFFSET BY EACH INDIVIDUAL
APPLICANT AND I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SHARE THAT- YOUR MODERATOR
PLEASE GO ON THE NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU AT THE NINE NINE
SEVENTEEN ONE NINE ELEVEN AT
THIS TIME WE'RE JUST TAKING
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION WE'VE HEARD FROM
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES TWO AND A
HALF. PRIMARY WITNESSES AND WE
WILL MOVE TO JUST NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. PINE
SEVENTEEN ALIGN OF THE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GERALD
APPEAR AND I AM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COMPORTS OFFICERS REPRESENTING
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS
STATEWIDE I'M CALLING AT THE
PORT OF SB ONE A ONE IN ASKING
COULD NOT BE PLACED INTO THE
SUSPENSE FILE EDIT VIEW THERE'S
NO ADDITIONAL COST TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
PERSON THE FIRST FOR THE
RECORD- AT MISMANAGING ALL THAT
JUST BECAUSE A BILL IS GOING ON
SUSPENSE DOESN'T MEAN IT'S NOT
GOING TO MOVE I MEAN WE WILL
CONFIRM IT'S UNDER
CONSIDERATION AS IT PROGRESSES
THROUGH THE SYSTEM. SO THAT
THERE IS A COST OF ESTIMATED
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND- FIRST YEAR COSTS AND
NINETY THOUSAND AN ONGOING
ANNUAL COSTS IT MET THE LEVEL
FOR SUSPENSE AND THAT'S JUST
WHAT HAPPENS BUT WILL GO TO THE.
NEXT SPEAKER IN SUPPORT. THANK
LINE EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAVID SPEARS
I'M A COLD HORSEMEN OFFICER FOR
THE CITY OF CARSON AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE A ONE AND I'M
ASKING THAT IT BE REMOVED FROM
THE SUSPENSE FILE THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE TWENTY FOUR TWO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LARRY
BROOKS DIRECTOR OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY HEALTHY HOMES PREVIOUS
CHIEF OF THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
DEPARTMENT- I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS THE ONE OH ONE THERE IS NO
COST TO HUMAN LIFE. OUR NEXT
COMMUNISM LINE FIFTEEN ONE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ACCERN
CALLER ON NINE FIFTEEN IS YOUR
PERSONAL DEVICE ON ME. HELLO MY
NAME IS CLEARLY MOST OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND
HOUSING ENFORCEMENT CHIEF WITH
THE CAPACITY OF SACRAMENTO I'M
CALLING TODAY IN SUPPORT SENATE
BILL ONE OH ONE. THANK YOU.
NEXT COMMENT IS FROM LINE
NINETEEN ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS AS BROTHER
DELYAN I'M CALLING FROM THE
CITY OF BELLFLOWER MCCARTY
FORCING OFFICER NEXT COURT SB
ONE A ONE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S JUSTIN OF SOMEONE TO
COME FOR SOME MANAGER WITH THE
CITY OF MONROVIA AND I'M ALSO
THE PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
COULDN'T FORCE AN OFFICER
SAFETY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
OF SB ONE A ONE. WE DO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL COMMENT ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. BLIND TWENTY FIVE TO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS RUBEN HERNANDEZ SOME A CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WITH THE
CITY OF SANTA ANA IN ORANGE
COUNTY. AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT SB ONE ON ONE HAND
THERE IS NO PRICE IN THE- ONCE
LIFE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NO OTHER LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED SB ONE A ONE SEEING
NONE ANYONE A ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSE SEEN NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION SB ONE A ONE NOW IS
YOUR OPPORTUNITY PLEASE QUEUE
THEM UP MR MODERATOR. THANK YOU
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
ONE OH ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD NEW PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHTS HAVING HEARD FROM
BOTH THE SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES WE WILL COME TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON SB ONE
A ONE. WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP- BEFORE I MOVE THIS TO
SUSPENSE JUST IN OUR SENATE
RULES OBVIOUSLY THERE IS A COST
AND THERE IS SOME OFFSETTING
REVENUE BUT IN OUR SENATE
RULES- WE STILL. PUT THINGS ON
SUSPENSE THAT HAVE A COST AND
SO THIS BILL WILL MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION- MOVIE AND THANK YOU
EVERYBODY FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
YOUR DUTIES AND FOR WAITING IN
TODAY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
PROCESS. AND THE COMMITTEE
APPRECIATES IT WILL MOVE ON TO
MISTER DOT S. B. ONE OH NINE-
OFFICE OF WILDFIRE TECHNOLOGY
AND RESEARCH THIS ITEM IS ALSO
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND MR
DOLLARS WAY PRESENTATION. AND
SO WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT FOR ANYONE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE SING
NINE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NONE MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP. THE
SUPPORT. FOR S. B. ONE OH NINE.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE S. B. ONE OH NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. YOU CAN USE YOUR
PHONE WE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. Q. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION. S. B. ONE OH NINE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE ON NINE. I DO APOLOGIZE
MISTER BELIEVE IT'S OPPOSITION.
I'M SORRY OPPOSITION YES
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION SB ONE ON
NINE. TO COMMENT ON S. B. ONE
OH NINE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL I MEAN PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
ONE OH NINE. THERE ARE NO LINES
IN Q. ALL RIGHT HAVING OFFER
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH FOR
AND AGAINST. SB ONE OR NINE AND
SEEING NINE WE WILL COME TO
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHICH DOES NOT HAVE A
FILING SB ONE ONE OH NINE WILL
COME TO THE COMMITTEE NO HANDS
GO UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION S. B.
ONE OH NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. LEON MISTER DODD
SECOND BILL ON CONTRACTORS
WORKERS COMPENSATION SB TWO
SIXTEEN THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATA MISTER DOT ITS WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
NOW SHOP TRINITY THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MISTER MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ONLINE. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
SIXTEEN. TO SPEAKIN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO SIXTEEN PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT COMMANDOS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT TO BE JUST ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF ELEVEN ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
MIGHT CANNOT BE ON BEHALF OF
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD SUPPORT THANK. THANK YOU
IN ORDER LINE TO KILL ALL RIGHT
WE MOVED OPPOSITION. THERE IS
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB
TWO SIXTEEN I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED TO SB
TWENTY SIXTEEN IS THERE ANYONE
ONLINE. IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWENTY SIXTEEN NOW IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO SIXTEEN
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
IT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY THEIR.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. HAVING OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR BOTH OF FOR AND OPPOSED
TESTIMONY IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES NOT OF
A FILE HONEST FIFTY SIXTEEN
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWO SIXTEEN IS
MOVES TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
LEVINE S. B. TWO OH EIGHT BY
SENATOR DOLLY ON SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY THIS ITEM IS ALSO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE EMERGED
ALWAYS WAY PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL MOVE RIGHT ON TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. NOW IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NO ONE IN THE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. AND MR MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE I IN SUPPORT. OF
S. B. TWO OH EIGHT. THANK YOU
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO OH EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY. ZERO I DO HAVE A LINE IN Q.
HE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OUR
COMMENTS TODAY WILL COME FROM
LINE FORTY FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HIGHLINE FORTY IS YOUR
PERSONAL DEVICE ON YOUR.
RESEARCHER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MOVE ON YES PLEASE. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO OH
EIGHT THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED IS NOW IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHICH MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ONLINE OPPOSED S. B.
TWO OH EIGHT. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO OH
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IN THE
COMMAND ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD IS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THERE ARE NO LANDING GEAR AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
HAVE A FILE ON S. B. TWO OH
EIGHT SO FOR SINGLE HAND FROM
THE COMMITTEE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TWO OH EIGHT IS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. BEYOND SB TWO
THREE SEVEN BY PORTANTINO ON
SPECIAL EDUCATION DYSLEXIA
SCREENING. HI THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND
OBVIOUSLY I PLAYED PRESENTATION
SO MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYBODY WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB
TWO THREE SEVEN I SEE NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM I SEE NO ONE IN
TWENTY FORTY. AND I SEE- MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE- QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
THREE SEVEN. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO THIRTY SEVEN
YOU MADE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE OF THEM IS THERE
OUGHT TO BE SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO THREE SEVEN. THERE ARE
NO LINE CAN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
COMPOSITION ANYONE OPPOSED SB
TWO THREE SEVEN. NOW IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY SEEING NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM SAYING THAT ONE IN
TWENTY FORTY- WE WILL MOVE TO.
THE- TELECONFERENCE LINE ANYONE
OPPOSED TO SPEAK SB TWO THREE
SEVEN ABSOLUTELY. YOU MISTER TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
THIRTY SEVEN YOU MADE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO LINES IN KIEL
HAVING OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES HAVE A FILE ON S.
B. TWO THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL AT THIS
TIME. WITH REGARD TO FISCAL WE
WOULD KNOW THAT THE BILL MAY
CREATE A PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATE. FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
ANNUALLY SCREEN ALL
KINDERGARTEN. THROUGH GRADE TWO
STUDENTS FOR DYSLEXIA. OF THE
COST OF THIS MANDATE WOULD BE
DEPENDENT ON THE SCREENING
INSTRUMENT THE L. EIGHT USES.
BUT COULD COST IN THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS TO THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. ADDITIONALLY
WE KNOW THE BILL CREATES ONE
TIME NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND STATE
OPERATIONS COSTS IN ALLOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. ORDER EDUCATION TO
ESTABLISH A LIST OF APPROVED
DYSLEXIA SCREENING INSTRUMENTS.
THE COSTS ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
RESEARCHING AND VETTING TOOLS
FOR POSSIBLE INCLUSION. ON THE
LIST BY JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. LASTLY THIS BILL
CREATES NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT STATE OPERATIONS COST
PRESSURE. FOR THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION TO REGULARLY
REVIEW AND UPDATE THE LIST OF
APPROVED INSTRUMENTS ONCE
ESTABLISHED. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WAS THAT A COMMON
RESTAURANT HOUSING YEAH I HAD A
QUESTION FOR FINANCE IF THEY
HAD AN ESTIMATE IF THIS MATTER
WAS. EXTENDED TO T. K. EFFORT
TO AND WE DON'T HAVE T. K.
EVERYWHERE BUT IF THE T. K. K.
ONE AND TWO DID THE TESTING
WHAT TYPE OF COST PRESSURES
THAT WOULD HAVE. I SENATOR I
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE AN
ESTIMATE FOR THAT AVAILABLE I
CAN GET BACK TO YOUR OFFICES
WITHOUT. OKAY GREAT AFTER THE
HEARING THANK YOU. RIGHT FOR
TICKETS NOT THAT WAS A FACTOR
FACT HE CABLED CORRECT YEAH.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU HAVING
ANSWERED THAT QUESTION WE AND
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWO THREE SEVEN HE
GOES TO SUSPENSE MOVING ONTO MR
STERN SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR- IT'S
ALSO SUSPENDS CANDIDATE IN
CENTER STARTED TO A
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONIES OR ANYONE.
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHTY
FOUR WHICH IS ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION SEEING NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM SING KNOWN IN TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT. OF S. B. TWO EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. DMI COMMANDOS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FORTY SIX FOUR SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE FORTY
SIX. YOUR LINE IS OPEN AT THIS
TIME. GOOD MORNING MARTHA IS
THERE ARE THOSE OF THE AS-
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER AND I'M SPEAKING ON
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY SEVEN I
DIDN'T HEAR THE CALL FOR
OPPOSITION. BUT WE ARE OPPOSED
TO TWO THIRTY SEVEN- THERE IS
NO FUN BEING IDENTIFIED IN THE
BILL FOR THE SCREENING OR OTHER
PROVISIONS CONTAINED IN THE
BILL AND AS SHOWN IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND COSTS ARE
ESTIMATED TO BE IN THE LOW TEN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EACH YEAR.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE GOT
THAT TO THIRTY SEVEN IN AND
WE'RE ON TWO EIGHTY FOUR
SUPPORT. AND THERE ARE NO LINES
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
GOING BACK TO TWO EIGHTY FOUR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S NO
ONE IN TWENTY FORTY. S.
MODERATORS ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION- TWO TO EIGHTY FOUR.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO EIGHTY FOR
ME PRESS ONE AMEND ZERO. AGAIN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
IT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. ALL RIGHT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO
EIGHTY FOUR- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES HAVE A FILE PLEASE
SHARE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
NOT THAT THE TOTAL COST OF THIS
MEASURE IS UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME
BUT IS EXPECTED TO BE
SIGNIFICANT. AS IT IS ESTIMATED
IMPACT OVER THIRTY STATE
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. OF THE FOLLOWING
DEPARTMENTS OF ESTIMATED COSTS
RELATED TO THEIR WORKERS COMP
EXPENSES. THAT CANNOT BE SO
ABSORBED THROUGH THEIR EXISTING
RESOURCES. THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES COSTS UP
TO THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD- ESTIMATES COSTS OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
ESTIMATES COSTS RANGING FROM.
FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED TO
FOUR HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY. THE
PHARMACY HOSPITALS DO NOT
PROVIDE AN ESTIMATE OF COSTS AT
THIS TIME BUT POLICE TO BUILD.
A CREATES COST PRESSURES.
ADDITIONALLY HAVE. SEVERAL
DEPARTMENTS- PORTED BACK THAT
THE COST WOULD BE OBSERVABLE OR
THAT THERE WOULD BE A MINOR OR
NO IMPACT COVER WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THEIR AN ADDITIONAL
SEVENTEEN DEPARTMENTS WHO HAVE
NOT REPORTED BACK AND WHO COULD
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT FISCAL
IMPACT ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
MEASURE.WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS US CDC ARE
CHARMING A VETERANS AFFAIRS AND
DEPARTMENT FISHING WILDLIFE. A
ISN'T CURRENTLY AVAILABLE- WE
ESTIMATE PRO PRELIMINARILY-
THAT COST ACROSS THE SPARTANS
COULD BE BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. LASTLY WE
ESTIMATE THE BILL COULD RESULT
IN SUBSTANTIAL FISCAL IMPACTS
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DUE TO THE
INCLUSION OF PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS PUBLIC SAFETY TELE
COMMUNICATORS. AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE COMMUNICATIONS
EMPLOYEES AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT THESE CLASSIFICATIONS ARE
SPECIFIC TO STATE AND LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES ARE NOT
SUBJECT PRIVATE- WE WOULD THE
BILL COULD CREATE A- AND DATE-
THE COST OF WHICH- WE
PRELIMINARILY ESTIMATE GIVEN
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY SIX
THOUSAND EMERGENCY DISPATCHERS.
ASSUMING A PTSD A RATE OF-APPROXIMATELY 30% WE ESTIMATE
THE MANDATE COULD COST BETWEEN
FIVE MILLION TO TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THANK YOU-
THANK YOU. SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP AND HAVING HEARD FROM
FINANCE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWO EIGHTY FOUR IS MOVED TO
SUSPENSE. WILL MOVE ON TO
SENATOR STERN BILL WHICH IS S.
B. TWO NINETY ONE ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION THIS IS ALSO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND SENATOR STERN IS
WAY PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT
ON TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY. FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFIED. I
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY S. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ONLINE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINETY ONE
ME PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. YEAH COMMANDOS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. LOCAL
CAROLINA FORTY SEVEN OR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOHN
BRADSHAW IS A GREAT QUESTION
FOR WHICH A CALIFORNIA AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL ON
BEHALF DISTRICTS AFTER NEEDS
LIKE MYSELF HAVING A VOICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THERE ARE
NO OTHER LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO NINETY ONE
SEE NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSING KNOWN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SO ANYONE ON THE IN THE
QUEUE ARE OPPOSED SB TWO NINETY
ONE. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO NINETY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. PM ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
OF SB. TWO NINE ONE. THANK YOU
LEARN ONLINE CAN KILL. ALL
RIGHT THE PARTMINER FINEST IS
NOT OF A FILING S. B. TWO
NINETY ONE THING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS TO NINETY
ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. LIVING
ON TO SB THREE OH FIVE FIVE
MISTER JONES ON THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT ELECTRONIC FILING.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AND MR JONES'S WAVE
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT ON
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH FIVE
SEEING NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
SEEING NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
STOP ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE OH FIVE. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH FIVE ME
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. GEN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE ZERO
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLONEL LINES INTO IT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT- BURGER OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE OH FIVE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM KNOWS OR
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY NO
MISSED MODERATORS OR ANYONE. IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE OH FIVE.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE OH FIVE
ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE. HOW DOES ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILING SB THREE
OH FIVE I SEE NO HANDS GO UP.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
OH FIVE WILL BE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE. FILE A SENATOR EGGMAN
HAS SB THREE SIXTEEN. WHICH IS
ON MEDICARE NOW THIS IS ALSO A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN MICHIGAN
HAS WAY PRESENTATION SO MOVE
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT. OF SB THREE
SIXTEEN HOURS YOUR OPPORTUNITY.
SIGNAL IN THIS ROOM SAYING NO
ONE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
MYSTERON RAIDERS ANYONE ONLINE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SIXTEEN PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE DO HAVE A
FEW LINES IN Q. WE'LL GO FIRST
TO LINE FIFTY FIVE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I HARD GAMBLE
EASTMAN WITH THE FEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN COURT. THANK YOU
NEXT AVAILABLE NINE SIXTEEN ONE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS CINDY HILLARY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE ONE SIX
THANK YOU. MAXALT ONLINE FORTY
TWO FOUR TWO TWO ONE IS OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE%
COMMITTEE REBEL HAGER
REPRESENTING THE PSYCHIATRIC
POSITIONS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL CALL FOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. THREE ONE SIX.
IN ORDER LINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TOP
POSITION OF SB THREE SIXTEEN
SAYING NO ONE IN THIS ROOM C.
KNOWN IN TWENTY FORTY- MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION SB THREE
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SIXTEEN
ME PRESS ONE NUMBER ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN NOT TO ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THANK YOU CAN
EARN A LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES
HAVE A FILE ON SB THREE
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME I WOULD
NOTE THAT WE ESTIMATED ANNUAL
COST RANGING FROM APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION OF WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND. TO SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OF WHICH
WOULD BE GENERAL FUND BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. DUE TO AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE VISITS. WE
HAVE TO MEET THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WOULD
REQUIRE SIXTEEN MILLION. TO
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS. EIGHT
MILLION TO TEN MILLION WHICH
WOULD BE GENERAL FUND. TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL. INCLUDING AYE READJUSTING
RATES FOR CLINICS AT THAT UP TO
DO SO. I WOULD WANT TO KNOW
THAT THE MAJORITY OF THIS
WORKLOAD I WOULD MATERIALIZE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND THAT IT IS HIGHLY DEPENDENT
ON THE BEHAVIORS CLINICS AND
THE AMOUNT OF RATE ADJUSTMENT
REQUESTED A RECEIPT. I WOULD.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FISCAL INTERMEDIARY TO
CHANGE THE CLAIM. TO ALLOW TWO
VISITS ON THE SAME DAY
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT THE
COST FOR THIS CHANGE- IS
UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME. THE BILL
CODIFIES EXISTING LAW BY ADDING
ACUPUNCTURE SERVICES IS
BILLABLE UNDER THE PROPOSED
EXPECTED PAYMENT SYSTEM RATE
AND THEREFORE WE DO NOT
ESTIMATED FISCAL IMPACT
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROVISION
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE'VE HEARD FROM EVERYONE
AS NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE SIXTEEN.
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WE WILL
MOVE TO MR LAYERED- SB THREE
TWO TWO ON. CONSERVATION
RANCHING INCENTIVE PROGRAM THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND MR
LEHRER IS WAY PRESENTATION SO
MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONIES OR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THREE TWO TWO
SEEING NO ONE IN THIS ROOM SING
KNOWN IN TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. THREE TO ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD ME PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWO TWO
SEVEN NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO NO ONE IN TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSE ANYONE ONLINE
OPPOSED SB THREE TWENTY TWO.
SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
TWENTY TWO IN A PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ALIGNED IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE. SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
TWO TWO. CLOSE TO SUSPENSE
PROVING TO SB FOUR TWENTY SIX
BY SENATOR RUBIO ON MUNICIPAL
SEPARATE STORM SEWER SYSTEMS
THIS IS  SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AND MS RUBIO HAS WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FOUR TWENTY SIX I SEE NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM I SEE NOBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR TWENTY SIX PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE ME PRESS ONE NUMBER
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT
ANY OPPOSITION THE SP FOUR
TWENTY SIX NOWSHERA FERTILITY-
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM NO ONE IS
TWENTY FORTY. IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR TWENTY SIX IN PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION OF SB. FOUR TO
SIX. YEAH THANK YOU KERN ONLINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THAT WAS
OPPOSITION RIGHT. IT WAS
OPPOSITION RIGHT- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
FOUR TWENTY SIX SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FOUR
TWENTY SIX. MOVES TO SUSPENSE
WILL NOW MOVE TO SB FOUR SIXTY
TWO BY SENATOR BORDERS ON
DISASTER RELIEF CREEK FIRE
ALLOCATION THE LOCAL AGENCIES-
HE HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
FOR ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF FORTY TWO OH
THREE. NOW IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE SB FOUR TWENTY SIX
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATORS ANYONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWENTY SIX.
APOLOGIZE MISTER JR IT'S A FOUR
SIXTY TWO BOARD BURGESS- I'M
SORRY FOR SIXTY TWO BORDERS
SHIPPED BY MISTAKE THANK YOU.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SIXTY TWO MAIN PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR SIX
TO. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. INTERNAL LINES IN Q.
MICROSOFT WORD NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION. MR NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED US BEFORE SIXTY
TWO NOW ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSED TO FOUR SIXTY TWO
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
UP THE OPPOSITION S. BEFORE
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR SIX TO
PRESS ONE THEM ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. CAN MINUS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO SPEAKING
OPPOSITION OF. FOUR SIX TWO.
AND THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON SD FOUR SIXTY
TWO I SEE NO HANDS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FOUR SIXTY TWO. WILL GO TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE MOVING ON SB
FIVE OH TWO BY MISTER ALLEN ON
GREEN CHEMISTRY CONSUMER
PRODUCTS- THIS ITEM IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND MR ALLEN
IS WAY PRESENTATION SO MOVE
RIGHT TO- TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
AND THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT AS A OF SB FIVE OH TWO
BY SENATOR ALAN. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE OH
TO ME PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THANK IN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD THE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE OH TWO. NOW IS THE
OPPORTUNITY SB FIVE OH TWO
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY ONE ONLINE
OPPOSED SB FIVE OH TWO NOW
WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
QUEUE THEM UP. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
OH TO ME PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
MY COMMANDERS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. I SHOWN ONLINE IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
HAVE A FILE ON SB FIVE OH TWO I
SEE NO ARMS GOING UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE OH TWO WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE. FILE
MOVING TO SB FIVE OH THREE BY
MISTER BECKER ON VOTING RIGHTS
BALLOT SIGNATURE VERIFICATION
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AND MR BECKER'S WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
NOW IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY I SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MISTER MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ONLINE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE
OH THREE. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE OH THREE YOU
MAKE YOU UP BY PRESSING ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD HMI PRESS BOND
THEM ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. OUR COMMENT COMES FROM
LINE FORTY NINE FOUR NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
I NEED TO TELL AND I AM A HIGH
SCHOOL STOCK MARKET ENGINE TO
CATCH THAT ARE SUPPRESSION%
BIPARTISAN SHOULDN'T RUN
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
THE ADVANCEMENT OF YOUR VOTER
RIGHT. AFTER THE U. S. SENATE
BILL FIVE OH THREE OUR
ORGANIZATION OF COMPLETE
CONCLUSION THAT THIS BILL WILL
HAVE A NET POSITIVE IMPACT ON
VOTING RIGHTS IN CALIFORNIA ONE
PORTION OF THE BILL THAT I
BELIEVE WILL HAVE A
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IMPACT
IS A REQUIREMENT ESTIMATING
REASONING ABOUT REJECTION TO
THE FACTORY STATE STREET
SECTION OF THE BILL IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AS ALL
GRANT MORE DATA PERTAINING TO
PROJECTIONS BALLOTS LEGISLATORS
AND CITIZENS. WHICH ALLOWED TO
BETTER INFORM BUILDING BUILT IN
THE FUTURE THIS SECTION WILL
ALSO INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO CONFIRM THAT
ALL ELIGIBLE BALLOTS ARE
COUNTED. OUR OUR ACCOUNT. THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME TURNOVER THE
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE OH
THREE SAYING NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM C. KNOWN IN TWENTY FORTY
MOST MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION SB FIVE OH
THREE. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE OH THREE
ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT- WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE
PORT AND OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT
FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE OH
THREE WILL THIRTEEN NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE A
THREE WOULD GO TO SUSPENSE. WE
HAVE OUR FINAL STILL ON FILE SB
FIVE FORTY THREE BY SENATOR
LIMON ON STATE AGENCIES
NONPROFIT. LIAISON THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN MS AMOUNT
IS WAIVED PRESENTATION SO MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB FIVE FORTY THREE
NOW IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY SINGH
KNOWN IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
SAYING NO ONE IN TWELVE FORTY
FIVE SEMI TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FORTY THREE. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FORTY THREE I MEAN PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
MOVE TOP POSITIONS OF SB FIVE
FORTY THREE. SAYING NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB FIVE FORTY
THREE SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE OPPOSED SB FIVE FORTY
THREE TIME IS THE MONTH. THANK
YOU TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE FORTY THREE YOU MAKE
YOU UP AT THIS TIME BY PRESSING
ONE AND THEN ZERO. I CAN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD HMI PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. I SHOWN
ONLINE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITIES. WILL
COME BACK TO THE PARMA FINANCE
WHICH IS NOT HAVE A FILE N SB
FIVE FORTY THREE COMING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE NO HANDS WENT UP
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
FORTY THREE IS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE. FILE MISTER CONSULT I
DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE ANYTHING
ON CALL- THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS SO IF THERE'S ANY
OUTSTANDING- COMMENTARY WELL
THERE'S NOTHING LEFT SEVENTY.
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION- YOUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF HE WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE EVERY OPPORTUNITY FOR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
RECORDS THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY AS I SAID
THERE ARE NO. OPEN ITEMS AND SO
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS
THANK EVERYBODYFOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION THAT
CONCLUDES OUR APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY. MAKE.